yo sub gqueues lil yachty and i'm going
undercover and it actually me first
[Music]
seriously it's actually me Twitter Danny
B's what's your favorite jewelry you
have does he spell my favorite right I
don't know why this [ __ ] pissing me
all what looks like fave right sounds
like chewing gum for old people with
sensitive teeth what's your favorite
jury that you have tell you when I'm at
home and I'm going some I do not wit I
only wear it for stuff like this it's
heavy it takes a long time to put on
it's cold not really much pluses to it
but it's answer your question probably
my teeth I would get permanent diamond
teeth if I didn't have money moves to
make but I got money to make yeah me who
does the ideas choreography your mother
[ __ ] I danced like little Saint Elaine
honestly I have like very minimal reply
how much do you spend on jewelry a
[ __ ] lot I thought one of them
[ __ ] buy it my recent person says I
bought a game system that was eight
thousand dollars and I bought a truck
that I really didn't need to buy looks
like it I spent a lot on jury you can
find out by watching my drivi don't
gqueues your aura from your quarter
me it's actually what motivates lugar D
for being honest
not much pretty lazy keep it a hundred I
think what motor they did do me in the
beginning was that I was dead broke and
I used to do very illegal things could
really landing in prison and I'm clearly
not fit for prison and everyone started
giving up on my mom she started thinking
I was spiraling out of control I could
tell people are losing faith so I was
like I had to prove everybody wrong you
know people just doubt and hate so much
but man family celebrity is a lot to it
you know it's so much that comes with
that submit Instagram ah man my skin is
so chocolatey right there Mikey got
bands acts how much do your braids cost
roughly a hundred dollars I get my hair
deal like once a week sometimes twice a
week sometimes it's like 150 sometimes I
just do like a upfront like 30 sessions
so like 4 grand
yeah expensive maybe when I get like 27
I'm gonna like go ball and get real buff
and go grow my sexy
you know I'm Sam just give it a sec see
like I got time you too this is Billy
gangchan it's just a gang gang gang
names and Lauren are bonito eggs where
do you get your chains so I thought that
mr. flawless and he's being very patient
with me he did attack me anchor he takes
me out they like to come get to [ __ ] so
I have John garden he did Bart Simpson
he did the lock Gabriel which is
Raffaello out here he did my my big
Cuban they did the chain of my face a B
goals who do my teeth and then icebox we
did majority of
doing oh and Wafi I can't forget wifey I
love Wafaa shots out the jury eliminate
that's why that's my girl
max outdoors TV acts name of the first
song he rapped on ever a song called
bitter but you know that blew up will be
one night I guess post-it Oh squeaking
do you play for tonight I stopped I used
to I stopped because this is why and
then my account just like shut off it
would freeze at the loading screen and
[ __ ] sucks I started playing on my
own gaming computer under like another
name but I just wasn't the same man stop
playing did I say got too [ __ ] hard
like people got way too good I haven't
won in [ __ ] months so I thought there
call the duty came round now red and so
definitely playing right dead right now
Jesus Christ Octavian I sound like the
kids you grow up wouldn't school who is
just bad Octavian Jackson he was always
an ISS always fighting Octavia sit down
don't just sound like whatever did they
sample the Doctor Who theme song or is
it just me it's just you Octavian
Jackson more Twitter June Melanie
eggs toast though yachties manager that
person is the real MVP it's close k
coaches through and VP which take is
mostly at your concerts hmm thank you
chosen so it'll be a tie between maybe
New York I want to say I like is not a
label Orange County is live but London
turns out that's not a state but London
is goes crazy
I got shows coming up everyone come
Candice Nicole PR says okay who is lil
yachty is booking agent
you cannot hate on his placements lately
right and now target respect I have an
amazing team seriously
couple years ago you wouldn't expect he
links his little black boy right here
you know you wouldn't think target would
want to put him on commercial part to do
it
my team and then my image enough had
tattoos all in my face and I walked
around with guns and you know I said I
almost slapped that [ __ ] it probably
wouldn't work you know some serious
question just though you already have a
yacht no now wish people would stop
asking me that because I don't I was
gonna buy a boat though like a pretty
nice sized boat and just sit in my
backyard like a tree house I got a
pretty nice big boat and then just sit
in the backyard already what happened to
yadi forever them a lot of EP he was
supposed to job that was going to sound
more like the boat one that's got
[ __ ] kind of like nervous I did
teenage emotions which was melodic which
was supposed to be like an addition to
the boat one it was a little bit more
pop it probably was too poppy but it was
more like you know and people [ __ ]
hated it like oh my god hate and was so
good to me and I really broke me like
people would say that's what you need to
make you do not do it they like [ __ ] on
it you know and then I started robbing
and putting out these projects from just
wrapping it they do better you know they
get a better response but things that
people say wait what happened to blah so
I said do a tea for everyone just to
have it our LOI P oh no I was going to
do it and then I'll just kind of
outskirts you LM oh for what instrument
does he play you [ __ ] like a guitar not
a joke for a life true story that's it
I'm signing off the internet
closed laptop Oh
signing off the internet